well a non-profit organization called
the white coat waste project has just
found that a lab in tunisia north africa
infected dozens of beagles with
disease-causing parasites this research
was funded by tony fauci's nih which
sent a 375 000 grant to the lab now
according to this non-profit the money
went to quote drugging beagles locking
their heads in mesh cages filled with
hungry sand flies so the insects could
eat them
alive
that's disgusting and the people who
funded it should be submitted to that
see how they like it by the way the
washington post today defended it a man
a columnist there called dana milbank
will defend literally anything
apparently his lot came up it was his
job to take one for the team so he wrote
a straight face piece saying complaining
about this is somehow immoral they'll
defend anything
kathy guillermo is senior vice president
at peta she joins us tonight kathy
thanks so much for coming on
look this is so offensive that it's hard
even to talk about it on tv but i want
to leave open the possibility that maybe
there's some reason that we had to
torture dogs to death
give us your view
there's no reason for the disgrace that
this experiment is and unfortunately
it's just the tip of the iceberg of
what's going on at nih nih buys
thousands of dogs they subject them to
experiments that only freddy krueger
could think up and all of this have to
has to change you know the last time i
was on here with you i said that
nih director francis collins needs to go
and fortunately since then he's
announced his resignation now the rest
of the nih directors need to go too
well that's exactly right i mean my
sense from reading a lot about this is
that many of these
torture sessions they're not even
experiments it's just torturing animals
who can't who love us and can't help
themselves
this is driven by funding so there's
money available so the experiment takes
place but it doesn't necessarily help
science or any people it's just
they need to spend the money
that's what we know and they spend about
19 billion dollars of it every year on
animal experiments even though we know
that these experiments are not going to
find cures and treatments for human
beings and if you look at their other
laboratories right inside nih's
laboratory in maryland experimenter
elizabeth murray as we exposed last year
brain damages monkeys and then tries to
frighten them in tiny cages with plastic
snakes and spiders
this kind of experimentation goes on all
the time if you look at the primate
center university of washington they're
full body irradiating monkeys destroying
their immune system completely and we're
all paying for this there's no reason to
do it it needs to stop
i
i feel sick just hearing these stories
why would anybody you see people
reflexively defend this stuff oh it's
science it's it's cruelty it's not
science but why would anyone defend this
defending the status quo seems to be the
default position of some people
unfortunately but that's not how we
progress as a society and we have to get
nih to come to terms with this and
remember that their constituency is not
the animal experimenters nih's
constituency is the american public
defending the status quo seems to be the
default position for a lot of people boy
i don't think i could have put it better
than that thank you for saying that
that's exactly right kathy guillermo
apita thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else